now we know that Adam Price will resign
as leader of the Welsh nationalist
leader of Applied Camry quite a long
statement has been issued in the last
minute or so because this national
executive council meeting has been
taking place tonight the NEC approved a
motion allowing applied to invite
nominations to the position of interim
leader at its meeting tomorrow and Adam
that was after Adam price in four
members he will be stepping down as
leader of the party wants interim
arrangements are in play so a new leader
should be in place we're told by the
summer and a timetable outlining the
process for electing a permanent leader
will be communicated to party members at
the earliest possible opportunity one
reason we think for this pretty
embarrassing delay is there's no obvious
successor to Adam Price especially once
you discount those who've committed to
moving to Westminster because of course
you're a leader of the Washington Welsh
nationalist was a seat here at the
center not who has a seat in Western so
a confirmation tonight Anna that Adam
Price will be stepping down as leader of
Clyde Camry the third party here at the
Welsh Parliament a process to invite
nominations for a temporary leader will
happen Tom tomorrow here at the senith
and then over the summer the process for
party members to elect a permanent
leader